you're doing that you guys are doing an
AMA later today right yeah we are now I
don't know o'clock East East Coast time
I don't know who's in charge of this
thing but I want you to tell them to
learn from Ken bones mistakes did you
hear about what happened to him no I
didn't account my new username for an
AMA you need a new user actually have it
read it username at all me neither
okay so we're not gonna read it I'm not
like trolling anything you know who can
bone was Sam so chem bone is the guy
yeah bit of a phenomenon yeah yeah yeah
he got a good five days yeah Wow when it
happened when he came up and asked the
first that question I was like it's Kay
bone time exploded and so so this is
this is Ken bone he it was the second
the right question yeah he was one of
the the gentleman that came up and asked
a question but I mean look at this
beautiful man
so he's crazy for awesome but he came
into a bit of controversy radiohead was
his favorite band by the way which I
thought was pretty awesome was that
buried in there under the bad stuff
maybe why we did an AMA right but he
used his reddit name that he's had for
years
oh and so they just clicked his name and
started going through all his old posts
and as it turns out he thinks Trayvon
Martin was justifiably murdered legal
term legal terms he's into pregnant porn
he loves his own body can have being
finding pregnant women sexy is kind of
alright that's probably the healthiest
one like well I like the idea I mean he
also he also posted a thing that said
that he liked Jennifer Lawrence's
butthole you don't want I don't know if
it's like total character assassination
no you I like Jennifer Lawrence's asked
Hall I'd love that to be on my rip why
not for you it'd be like that shows
thing you never said
it was also like a photo that was not it
was when all those photos were stolen is
the fastening and that's not right right
right right that's not good he was just
a guy who asked the question at the
presidential debate and the internet
just went crazy for him because he's a
big fat guy in a red sweater with a
mustache yeah and said they just went
nuts for him
yeah well perfectly round skull I think
people are gonna go nuts for Dirk
gently's holistic I want to get that